I'm about to ask Maurice jones-drew this
question as well as he joins us here on
the Rich Eisen show Maurice I'm gonna
ask this right off the bat when I asked
uh Irvin and Marshall um how come teams
like the Falcons cannot find Julio Jones
with the regularity that Big Ben keeps
sending to his guy that he knows is
going to be double covered half the time
well I feel like Big Ben forces the ball
to Antonio Brown sometimes it works well
most majority time it works other times
it doesn't rich so I think with Matt
Ryan they're trying to run the ball
they're trying to use play-action pass
and Matt Ryan's not trying to literally
just for speed who you're done with I
would love him for him to do because he
is on one of my fantasies but you know
it's one of those bills where Big Ben
knows where his bread is buttered and
Matt Ryan's trying to be a kind of a
complete quarterback where he's
spreading the ball around that's why you
see Mohamed Sanu that's why you see
Hooper there tied in sometimes their
running back to get into it and Taylor
Gabriel could cabal done as well well I
mean but Big Ben's got levee on bail and
juju Smith Schuster has come to the fore
this year Jesse James scored a touchdown
last night martavis Bryant even got it
so then spreading the ball around both
Marshall and Irvin were saying that that
Todd Haley's just a better offensive
coordinator who knows where to put put
his guys in position and knows what
routes to run based on the defense that
he's seeing out there that's being
called well I'll take you back to
Pittsburgh Lyon the Pittsburgh Steelers
Lions game where Big Ben threw a pick
and it was four guys covering a Antonio
Brown so that's what I say forces the
ball sometimes is good you know 80 can
go over two guys and going into five
Julio Jones can but in certain
situations he'll throw some pick
sometimes do they have to kind of lead
on the running game I thought the
Tennessee Titans though last night did a
great job of kind of limiting lately on
Bill and then forcing Big Ben to throw
into double coverage and when you throw
50/50 balls sometimes they don't go your
way other times they do there is you
know and I feel like juju Smith juicers
opened up some room for Antonio Brown
that getting Brian back even though
they're still trying to get him in his
groove
he's opening up some room as well but
you know again it comes to the
quarterback just really
just trying to force the ball when you
look at you know I work for the RAM so
when you look at the Rams
Jarett golf doesn't force the ball
anymore he throws it to the open guy and
that's what Matt Ryan's kind of trying
to do well I mean in maurice jones-drew
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
NFL Network's and now as I mentioned
earlier as he just mentioned Ben calling
ramjee games since they returned to Los
Angeles on the local radio
I mean golf's thrown open guys because
in many ways they're being schemed open
I mean what Sean McVeigh has done is
truly remarkable from last year to this
but what they're lost to Seattle that
happened in Los Angeles mjd and you're
seeing you know what Carson Wentz is
done in Philadelphia and Drew Brees
being somebody who had been able to
watch for quite some time people still
aren't buying the Rams nationally I
don't think as a deep viable threat this
year what makes you think that they are
well I can understand that the first
half of their schedule has been pretty
mediocre but we have to remember they
won they beat Dallas and Dallas when
they had seat they really they literally
threw the game away against the Seahawks
I want to say if anything move all up
and down the field they have five
turnover and still almost won the game
at the end if Cooper cuts if Cooper cup
catches a touchdown where he's wide open
and so I feel like you know again when
you're talking about a team that's in
first place right now and the Seahawks
have been kind of running the league for
a while no one's going to give you
credit until you beat the C it's the
Seahawks in Seattle so we've been saying
this all along like all this is great
and we have a tough test this week
against the Vikings we're a Vikings
defense is playing really well and they
Case Keenum playing well they're running
the ball and there's really good things
going on but in order for the Rams to be
where they want to be they have to win I
want to say that week 13 games we 13 or
14 game in Seattle you beat them in
Seattle then you get the crown and you
become the king and then you get all the
recognition that you want well I mean
they first up have a week it's it's
incredible I mean the Rams are gonna
earn it if they do make it to the
playoffs and if that well I think
they're gonna make it to the playoffs if
they do win the division or even a bye
week because on their schedule are all
three current other division leaders
and Seattle still left on it because
they've got home games against the
Saints and the Eagles on top of it all
which is the best team that you've seen
in person this year Maurice oh the best
team I think they face to this point
[Music]
it's probably going to be the Dallas
Cowboys in the first half I thought they
played uh you know one of those games
you saw Jacksonville in person what
about them now that they're half a calf
game in first place in there if you
again we understand Jacksonville
phenomenal first and foremost the way
they fill that defense I got to give
credit to Gus Bradley and Dave Caldwell
for building a defense that is you know
arguably one of the best in the end in
league history and what they're doing
right now I think they're averaging less
than 14 points a game or something like
that if something something crazy but
the Jags are good but if you stop their
running game you make a one-dimensional
they're easier to beat I think when you
play the Cowboys you could try to stop
their running game to be still have Dez
Bryant on the outside you still have
some Jason Witten you still have dag
Prescott who could beat you with his
legs as well so the Jags are playing
better and I think the reason they're
playing better late Bordeaux's turn the
ball over but uh that game after I want
to say Linder if we're gonna have that
big run they're deepens kind of settled
in and really held limited the Jags off
into a couple first downs in the second
half so um the I think the thing about
the Rams that people are starting out
like starting to see a little bit rich
is that their complete team they run the
ball they can throw the ball
they could play solid defense at number
one and special teams and that's what's
going to win them games you talk about
that Jacksonville Jaguars game where
Farrell Cooper returns a kickoff return
to start the game off and gives them a
chances scored then punt to may block a
punt and then score as well so they're
finding ways to win and they have a team
that's you know they kind of they
utilize each other there's not one side
more dominant does a couple more minutes
with Maurice jones-drew my buddy from
the NFL Network here on the Rich Eisen
show a longtime friend of this program
in the podcast before levy on bail last
night scores a touchdown
then they buzz down and
fractions of an inch take the touchdown
away from him and Todd Haley calls a
play-action pass Marshall Faulk was
sitting in the green room saying man I
would be pissed off what do you think
Maurice would you do if you had that
happen to you well first of all I love
your celebration after he scored did you
know that they're getting back to the
old the old good games to keep away and
things like that but I would Marshall
hit it right on the head I would be
livid I mean I'd be pissed off I'd have
to go to Todd Haines we'd have to talk
after the game I know we're winning and
that's good and dandy but you know you
got to give you you gotta feed your
workhorse a little bit give him a you
know a treat here and there especially
if it get you down to the inch yard line
and grant may was a great call knew you
were gonna score there but try to get
lady on the ball and see if he can get
it in itself I mean he did a lot of the
works getting to that point so I know
where Marshalls coming from any time
you're a playmaker rich and you know
this you play one of the guys you work
with herb is a player's be playmakers
right yes those guys want the rock and
you know you can actually loose or any
other coach about if you get a star
player on your team expressly one with
the ability of lady on bill who has been
very quiet you know because he's still
on his franchise tag and you haven't
heard much problem he's been a great
model citizen and we call the league a
team player I would literally you know
you'd want to go talk to Tyler listen
next time we get that situation let's
try to give me the ball a little bit
more yeah right so you think he did say
something entirely after the game last
night
what are you - 17 wins I don't think he
did we have the same agent I talked to
him last night
Lady Anne was good you know again
they're winning and he knows there's
gonna come a point in the time where you
know similar last year he's gonna get 33
34 35 carries in the game and he's gonna
score multiple times in that game so
he's being patient he's just land
everything play out the way needs to
play out and did you hear the Big Ben
audible during the game last night yeah
he went yeah he did the old he did the
old dilly dilly last night right there
did you ever suggest to your quarterback
a inaudible that then was used I mean
how do these things come about in
meeting rooms and things like that
mjd well every you know when you're
watching yourself
teams or certain formations and certain
downs and dishes that are going to kind
of dictate what they want to do we had a
play I forgot what we called it but we
knew we were playing at jazz my rookie
year we knew in a certain town and disc
they would go a zero glitch and so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna fake like
I was blocking they kind of leaked out
and there should be no one there and I
forgot what the name of it was it might
have been called brown shoe there's
something simple like that
why cause like Coughlin had a brown shoe
or something like that or like that
coaches are like we don't know anything
we want and brown shoe just seemed like
the you know the most simplest thing to
do and we call it work right so it's
just funny I mean you can use anything
some I think he was saying Billy Billy
is too hurry up to be honest that
similar to like Peyton Manning's Omaha
okay or some of these other guys are
saying turbo or ready ready or whatever
it may be but you didn't I mean does it
I'm just wondering what the genesis of
this is you never made a suggestion like
hey I'd like to give a shout-out to my
bud or my favorite TV show my favorite
movie you never did anything like that
when you're there running back you
rarely get any say-so so this is Big Ben
who likes the commercial basically so
what it is pretty much he's telling you
he's giving them a shout out
probably has a sponsorship deal or
something never know these quarterbacks
alright mjd enjoy the game in Minnesota
that's gonna be a big one will be all
watching and listening rich is gonna be
27 degrees outside you know I'm from
California not built for all that you
see juju Smith Shuster from Long Beach
Poly by way of USC came out without
sleeves during the post game last night
guy trying to be a tough guy you know it
UCLA we're smarter than that we don't
have to show them yeah I was about to
say break it down for me darn old verses
Rosen what happens this weekend you know
I think Donald throws about three picks
UCLA finally will stop the run this week
Darla's throw three forcing their double
coverage Josh Rosen running that pro
style offense will do a great job of
just dissect in this defense and it'll
be it'll be a good game
but we'll win by let's say 12 points so
the games not in China is it MJG right
you co III is it too soon tell me if
it's too soon is it too soon
no no it's never too soon it's never too
soon I feel like they did a great job at
their press conference okay really
emitting their faults and then we just
have to move on but I choose not to you
know cuz I'm a big big baller brand fan
aren't you if lebara bar is listening I
didn't need a shirt or a hat er dilly
dilly well done ma'am JD we'll chat soon
you got it there's Maurice jones-drew
that's great dilly dilly dilly for more
Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
Channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Rich Eisen show app